ACF Brill motors companies Philadelphia pioneer
in the production of transportation equipment
one of the leading manufacturers of buses in the
nation but these aren't buses being put together
their army trucks being taken apart worn-out
broken-down army trucks that are stripped to
the last nut and bolt to be reconditioned and
rebuilt good as new in the company's machine
shop parts that merely require re boring or
refinishing or put back in shape many new
parts are also fabricated here along with tools
that help speed up the work rebuilt motors get a
three and a half hour test run on the dynamometer
that checks on horsepower rating oil pressure so
on certified as being in a one condition it's
moved along to the assembly line to be lowered
into place in a truck whose other parts have
been undergoing equally comprehensive overhaul
ACF Brill with its long experience in
the manufacture of streetcars buses and
trailers as well as its achievements in
producing for the military in two world
wars was well equipped to assume vital tasks
like this when trouble broke out again among
its facilities heat-treating equipment
in which metal is made ready to be for
the forming is done on a giant
Kirk sight pres biggest in the
Philadelphia area vendors can be shaped
here or side panels or parts for the cab
wheels are fabricated right here in the
plant and most of the trucks require new
tires all around on the assembly
line the cab is dropped in place
all the old parts that go back on the
truck have of course been scraped down
to the bare metal and repainted the
contract with Uncle Sam calls for
about the same specifications as are
demanded for trucks that are brand new
finally they're ready to return to the service
of the mission the men who rebuilt them are also
serving the nation with trucks and other rolling
stock essential to the country's well-being